[Music]
an estimated 152 million children are
being put to work around the world
hard manual labor in minds in fields
on family farms
in africa one in five kids are involved
in child labour
girls are especially vulnerable the
number of children at work is said to
dramatically worsen because of the
pandemic
as it wreaks havoc on family incomes
many parents could put their kids to
work
more than a billion children in 130
countries have been affected by school
closures
and child labour has risen in line as
school gates
banks shut the organization for economic
cooperation and development has told dw
that children are paying the largest
price in this pandemic
director for education and skills under
isla praises the countries that have
managed to keep schools open
we need to be aware of the high social
costs that school closures have
for children and that's why you know i
value countries you know like
france and italy and uh to some extent
even spain that you know despite very
difficult pandemic
contexts have given education absolute
priority
india allowed schools to reopen in
october but some children will only head
back now
due to a staggered resumption of classes
many children in india's villages may
not return at all
we traveled to uttar pradesh
asad rahman started apprenticing six
weeks ago at this furniture shop
in a village in uttar pradesh the shy 12
year old has been half-heartedly
listening to instructions
he's clearly not enjoying it
i want to go back to school meet my
friends
i don't want to work here but he doesn't
really have an
option nor does his younger brother
ashjad
who joined him here a few days ago
both are following their father's
instructions
abdul rahman is out of work himself
with schools closed for nearly a year
now due to the coronavirus
he has given up hope their education
will secure them work
rahman says he's only looking out for
their future
schools have been closed they were
studying they not
school available the state government
has just announced that junior classes
are set to resume
but assad and ashjad may need to stay at
work to support their family
high school classes resumed back in
october
but children younger than 15 years have
hardly studied for the better part of a
year
at best they while away their time
playing with their friends
at worst they are forced into labor or
are married off
kuthuba deen chaudhary has worried
endlessly about this
especially about the 400 children who
attended his school
his class is much smaller now he just
helps his own daughters with their
studies
private schools like chaudharys educate
close to half of india's children
often for very little money now
his own school survival is at stake
chaudhary waved his 100 rupee or
approximately one euro monthly fee
during the lockdown he still fears that
many can't afford to continue sending
their children
most of the children are accompanying
their parents to work
i fear 70 of them will drop out
we try to appeal to the parents to keep
educating their kids
but they just say if we don't have money
how are we supposed to send our children
to school
the lack of resources also rules out
online education
chaudhary says if parents
already can't afford a nominal fee how
can they pay for multiple smartphones
for all the children at home
education has not been a priority in his
village he says
and it had been an uphill battle even
before the lockdown hit
chaudhary is excited to see the children
again soon
but he is also realistic he knows
that even if just a quarter of them show
up
he can count it as a victory
if at idris is an expert on child labor
in south asia and joins us from the
university of birmingham in the uk
what's causing this huge jump in child
labor during the pandemic
um well thank you for having me um i
think it's all the
effects of the pandemic are also drivers
of child labour so the pandemic is
causing an economic shock
across the world but it's particularly
felt in developing countries it's
causing a rise in poverty
it's closing schools which traditionally
protect children from
child labour it's causing even less
enforcement of child labor laws and
regulation
and it's meant that cs civil society
organizations can't protect children and
monitor them
so for all those reasons a pandemic is
leading to a rise
in child labour what about the checks
and balances you mentioned schools there
and regulations but
have are the checks and balances simply
gone out the window in this pandemic
well checks and balances in developing
countries tend to be weak anyway because
of limited
government capacity so as i said
employers now have more of a free reign
to to use children and to exploit them
because
governments for attention is focused on
on dealing with the pandemic and civil
society organizations are not able to
carry out
the protective role that they normally
would but schools i think schools are
the real significant
sort of protector of children and that
has been removed when you take kids out
of schools
in developing countries you greatly um
increase their risk of expo
of being forced into into work just
briefly of course sending these kids
into work rather than to school
limits their prospects what what does it
do what's the impact
on the world on the global economy
well it's it's kind of like i i think
about it is if you sort of throw stone
in water and you see ripple effects
so child labour has the same kind of
ripple effect which
which which you know spreads outward so
the child themselves they're affected
because they can't
study they're exposed to physical labor
often physical abuse verbal abuse even
sexual abuse
but in the long term that child then
grows up
to be in low paid work to be unemployed
um to be um doing hazardous work
and critically child laborers grow up
into adults who then send their own
children out to work
and so you get this intergenerational
cycle of poverty child labour property
child labor
and that impacts collectively as a
society and as a country that
greatly hampers economic growth and
development
and that then poverty under development
those are both
major contributory factors to all kinds
of other problems
like armed violence conflict
radicalization extremism
illegal trafficking illegal migration
human trafficking and those have
consequences for everyone
but i think you know that the point i
really want to stress is that
you know we we need to address people in
the developed world need to address this
problem
not just because down the road it will
come back to hit
us here but because we have a moral
responsibility to do so these are
children
children have the right to you know a
future
and to be secure and safe and have
opportunities and we all need to
support them in doing that and as you
pointed out there that the longer term
effects are even longer than than one
would expect if an idris
thank you very much for joining us today
thank you for having me now it's that
part of the show where derek williams
fields your questions on the coronavirus
so what do we currently know about when
the pandemic actually started
more than we did at this time last year
but not a
whole lot more a recent who mission that
spent
weeks in china investigating the origins
of the pandemic
came to a few unsurprising conclusions
the first was that its members agreed
that sars
cov2 had originated in bats
which other experts have more or less
been saying the whole time
um the second was that it believed the
virus
had jumped to humans via an unidentified
second species which is more information
that's
pretty old hat although they did say
that they suspected
it might be a small mammal which was a
specification that was
sort of new i guess the mission also
said it considered it
extremely unlikely that sars kovi ii
had somehow escaped from a wuhan lab
that specializes in bat viruses although
that assessment remains pretty
controversial
really for me the most interesting
takeaway
was this we can also
agree that we have
found evidence of wider circulation of
the virus
in in december it was not just
only a cluster outbreak
in the juanan market but the virus was
also circulated
outside of the markets that's new um
up until now the working hypothesis was
that covet 19
first struck at a wet market in wuhan
around the beginning of december of 2019
but
if it was already in wider circulation
in the city at that point
that means a couple of things first that
the wet market wasn't ground zero
and then of course that we have to push
back the timeline
of the original zoonotic jump a while um
although a few studies looking at how
the virus has evolved
say the earliest date their models
predict for a possible
jump is october of 2019.
so we learned something from the who
experts
maybe not all that earth-shaking but
interesting and and to be fair uh no one
expected the mission to figure out
everything about the pandemic's origins
in a couple of weeks um the wheels of
this kind of scientific
detective work uh turn very slowly
and as we heard earlier the pandemic has
put the welfare of children around the
world
in peril
the smiles behind the masks speak
volumes and education is a powerful
weapon to secure their futures
germany's daycare centers and elementary
schools are open again after two months
wales youngest pupils are returning in
the first step towards reopening schools
and in israel where vaccination rates
are high elementary school and the last
two years of high school classes have
resumed
in towns with cadentian rates under
control
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon